let's get into that first story from the
New York Post Elon Musk fires Twitter
lawyer James Baker over Hunter Biden's
story suppression the funny thing is you
know if you just read the headline
you're like uh-huh why is that news okay
Elon Musk fired Twitter general counsel
in case he was just straight general
counsel wow in light of concerns about
Baker's possible role in suppression of
information important to the Public
Public dialogue he was exited from
Twitter today musk wrote on Twitter
Tuesday musk added that he questioned
Baker before his firing about the events
surrounding the laptop suppression uh
Scandal and that his explanation was
unconvincing Baker was previously
general counsel for the FBI under former
director James Comey and was a key
figure in the bureau's investigation
into false claims of collusion between
Russia and Donald Trump's 2016
presidential campaign full stop
the day I believe it was the day Donald
Trump was inaugurated a lawyer tweets we
are going to impeach you that lawyer
later went out to represent a client
whose name we won't say and then he uh
imp he was part of the impeachment
against Donald Trump there have been
people actively working against the
president and the American people since
2016. how this man comes to leave in
disgrace the FBI and then become general
counsel for Twitter it's very very
interesting especially when you take a
look at some of this other information
let me see if I can pull this up we have
Josh Holly there uh where do we have it
is it there we go America First legal
following the Twitter files AFL has been
obtained new documents uncovering a
secret Twitter portal U.S government
officials used to censor dissenting
covid-19 views and violate the First
Amendment so uh this is something more
than just in my opinion
the FBI advising Twitter giving giving a
humble warning to Mark Zuckerberg no
they had Direct access and they had some
of their loyalists inside the company
Matt taibi writes on Twitter
on Friday the first installment of the
Twitter files was published here we
expected to publish more over the
weekend many wondered why there was a
delay we can now tell you part of the
reason why on Tuesday Twitter Deputy
general counsel okay so it was Deputy
Jim Baker was fired among the reasons
vetting the first batch of Twitter files
without knowledge of New Management the
process for producing the Twitter files
involved delivery of two two uh two two
journalists Barry Weiss and me via a
lawyer close to New Management however
after the initial batch things became
complicated over the weekend while we
both dealt with obstacles to new
searches it was Barry Weiss who
discovered that the person in charge of
releasing the file was someone named Jim
when she called to ask Jim's last name
the answer came back Jim Baker my jaw
Hit the Floor says Weiss
look at this the first batch of files
both reporters received was marked
Spectra Baker emails Baker is a
controversial figure he has been
something of a zelig of FBI
controversies dating back to 2016. from
the Steele dossier to the alpha server
mess he resigned in 2018 after an
investigation into leaks to the press
the news that Baker was reviewing the
Twitter file surprised everyone involved
to say the least new Twitter Chief Elon
Musk acted quickly to exit Baker Tuesday
reporters resumed searches through
Twitter files materials a lot of it
today the next installment of the
Twitter files will appear very uh at
Barry Weiss stay tuned
so how you guys doing
yeah I actually talked about this guy
yesterday
um and I brought up Jonathan turley's
article on him and he called them the
Kevin Bacon of the Russian collusion uh
Scandal the the story here is just
absolutely bewildering especially when
you look into the greater details this
guy was fired from the FBI for leaking
information on the Trump Administration
this guy was behind a lot of the major
warrants that were spying on the Donald
Trump campaign this guy then was working
with Vijaya Gotti one-on-one when it
came to censoring people in our
political landscape predominant people
who supported the Trump Administration
this guy's connected to the clintons
he's connected to James Comey he's
connected to almost virtually everyone
in the political sphere and Elon Musk
didn't even know he was working at
Twitter deciding what kind of documents
Barry Weiss and Matt taibi were getting
what that's how does that make sense it
does it does that make sense to you
absolutely not and you know what this is
just another great example too of just
how far the tentacles of our government
stretch in every aspect of our reality
and of our truth I mean going into again
big Tech which is one of the areas and
places where people cast their votes
where they gather their information
where their entire reality is dictated
essentially you have the FBI here
dictating reality dictating truth and
dictating what we're allowed to see so
you know even it's like our own
government right we instill somebody as
president who we think is going to
change things but then they have to go
through all of these other layers of
corruption and that's what we're seeing
right now with Twitter and all the other
you know people involved with even
suppressing the Twitter files it doesn't
surprise me that there was some deep
State act and when I say deep State I
mean like administrative State you know
I know very well that people will leave
the government you mentioned this
earlier Tim and then go work at Monsanto
or there'll be like a Monsanto Chief and
then they'll come work at the government
or they'll be like
it's just this revolving door of
government corporate collusion I just
have this is kind of the first time I've
seen it in social media well there's a
saying once your CIA you're always CIA
to think to think that the Federal
Bureau of Investigations doesn't have a
similar role in our private sector is
foolish so I think it's fair to say that
the FBI has infiltrated many big Tech
social media companies whether
officially or unofficially and a lot of
the times it is them calling the shots
here and prove me wrong because there's
no other way to to see this from the
plethora of evidence that has been
provided to us
yeah I kind of just don't think that the
country exists anymore I saw you tweet
that earlier too what do you mean by
that I mean that um
the idea of the United States is now
this shell you know you can see the flag
but even the embassies flying a
different embassies are flying different
flags in some places not like flying on
the flagpole but they're putting up like
the pride flag and stuff like that you
go to a major city the attitude the
belief structure is so dramatically
different from people outside of cities
it's like just it's a clear distinction
here then you get to the courts
okay it's a league uh there's we call it
we call it illegal immigration for a
reason okay well a whole bunch of States
just completely ignore that law right
California for instance they call it a
sanctuary State you've got places like I
think New York and San Francisco were
doing this Upstate New York allowing
non-citizens to vote yeah now that these
court cases are going through look the
southern border is completely porous
non-citizens are voting what does that
even mean how is it a vote if people who
don't live here can change the way we
have to live then you have all of the
crime then you have this two things with
this that's why I say the US doesn't
exist anymore
you know I was I was talking about this
earlier with the um
some friends they're like don't you
think but this stuff's always been
happening and I'm like yeah you know
back in the day of jedger Hoover when
he's digging up dirt on presidential
candidates and stuff but you see the FBI
they were everywhere they had some there
was like some unified authoritarian
controller of this country now not only
can we see them doing it but we see them
doing it you know what I mean like we
know they do it and now we're watching
them do it meaning their control has
been completely subverted so there's
illicit activity going on from the the
federal government to try and control
things which they're failing to control
and then they're being exposed so not
only is there no seemingly functional
law enforcement if you look at what
happened with Marjorie Taylor green if
you look at what happens with us if you
look at what's happening with police
across the country and Security in
Philadelphia like you were mentioning
these armed guards outside the cops
can't do anything the FBI can't do
anything swattings are happening like
crazy to members of Congress and now
we're just sitting back literally
watching in real time the FBI fail to
pull off an infiltration wow and I think
think what we're seeing too right in the
modern days if you really take a step
back and look at it is that all of our
intelligence agencies have been
weaponized against the American people
and then you go to the Border like you
talked about Tim I've been to the Border
myself and I've watched the flood of
illegal immigration that happens every
single day I've talked to border patrol
who say uh we're essentially Uber for
the illegal immigrants at this point
there there's no stop to the flow there
we're essentially aiding and abetting
human trafficking at our border we're
aiding and abetting the cartel at this
point the Biden Administration might as
well be putting money directly in their
pockets because they are and so again
you know the borders an issue the
crime's an issue and then on top of all
of that our own intelligence agencies
are now attacking and uh you know
targeting the American citizens so I
completely agree with your sentiment
that the United States no longer exists
and it was funny too because so many on
the left were saying oh my gosh Donald
Trump called to abolish the Constitution
this is so horrific I can't believe he
would say something like that it's like
hold on you guys impede on our first
amendment rights and our Second
Amendment rights every single day we
just had Joe Biden the other week saying
we need to ban assault weapons every
single day you have the Democrats trying
to take away our our Second Amendment
right our ability to defend ourselves to
keep us from becoming New Zealand China
or Australia and you're mad because
Donald Trump said something about
abolishing the constitution on true
social get you know give me apparents
say that he's like some rules including
some of those in the Constitution may
have to be suspended or Terminators I
think Terminator is what he said so he
didn't come out and say like terminate
the entire Constitution he was like some
of these rules have to be terminated
okay not a fan not a fan of when Abraham
Lincoln did it but Abraham Lincoln did
it too just saying I get the vibe that
the internet has changed the way Nations
govern themselves so drastically this
internet video and things like that now
like the the cohesion of
um the the myth of what we are used to
be through ABC NBC CBS and they were
told to you and that was the
administrative State now now everyone
it's it's Madness it's Madness and
Nations I think rightfully so are
dissipating like the idea that we that
the United States and ends at that drawn
out line is ridiculous now those people
on the other side like the cartels you
mentioned are just as much a part of
this system as I am whether I want it to
be or not we're all in this together so
it's it's it's faltering I don't think
that it means that the American ideals
are disappearing I think that the
Constitution and the idea is that it
represents are fantastic and could be
globally adopted you know you see
revolution in China with Ian the fact
that our own press secretary has the
audacity to get up in front of the
American people every single day and lie
to us boldface you know this
Administration tried to change the
definition of recession as we were
actively going through it this entire
Administration tries to pretend that the
economy isn't failing that inflation
isn't at a 40-year high the fact that
our own government is not fearful of the
American people and and you know they're
willing to lie to us so both fees it
really pisses me off and I think it goes
to show that yeah we don't have the
country that we once had you know Jack
busovic always loves to tweet that out
that the America that we once knew no
longer exists and I completely agree
with that sentiment because think about
the fact that we're raising an entire
generation that thinks that this type of
government is normal that changing the
definition of things is normal I was
thinking about the fact that TSA right I
thought that that was a normal thing I
wasn't aware that taking off your shoes
getting frisked by the TSA was not a
normal part of modern day Society think
about the fact that gen Z is going to
think that face masks that government
overreach that the government's spying
on you that the government lying to you
and redefining our modern day language
is just how Society has always run let
me I'll make a point to the uh country
no longer existing too there are a lot
of people that still believe in the
United States and they're holding to
this idea on this Vision I respect that
I I like what America represents I like
the Constitution but come on take a look
at the Constitution take a look at the
Bill of Rights is the federal government
abiding by the Bill of Rights let's
let's go through it the first amendment
what did we just learn okay well the FBI
the DHS dni are colluding with big Tech
platforms to censor legitimate legal
speech major political parties like the
DN C which includes public officials are
actively suppressing speech and we can
see it's happening in California we can
see it from the Missouri lawsuit that's
that's the first amendment is gone
Second Amendment oh I don't even got to
talk about that come on Democrats are
trying to ban semi-automatic weapons
third amendment I got you there baby
during coven they were mandating that
you couldn't evict people and that meant
and this is hilarious by the way that
active duty soldiers military personnel
who are currently living as tenants in
in property they could not be evicted
and I gotta say that literally violates
the third amendment the third amendment
of course most people don't realize is
you the government can't quarter
soldiers in your home so the argument
was actually made Fourth Amendment oh
come on the fourth has that one existed
for a long time NSA lying to Congress
they've bulk spying all of that stuff
tapping the deepsea cables come on those
are the first four that are gone how
about the Fifth Amendment oh boy you
want to go through this one January 6th
defendants how long have they been
locked up without charge without without
trials in solitary confinement I get
edit the list goes on there's no there's
no right to confront your accuser
there's no speedy trial let's talk about
the 9th and Tenth Amendment oh boy do we
got to go there look
you've got the fracturing across the
board of the Constitution it's just
non-existent sorry to say when you
brought up Trump I was going to make a
joke I was like we have a constitution
here but but you've made the point a lot
more clearer by going through each of
the Amendments here and yeah which one's
the seventh is that is that the one
about suing someone for 20 bucks or is
that which one is that one I don't know
I'm gonna I'm gonna look it up right now
but but there is something to say about
you know Rogue intelligence states that
have pretty much just destroyed
conversations destroyed speech destroyed
people's ability to to just have a fair
political system it what's happening
right now is not fair what's happening
right now is not just it's it's one
party consolidating enough power and
authority for themselves to do whatever
they want trying to create a
chinese-style totalitarian Society where
they try to disarm you put you on a
social credit score as you're going to
be living through a central bank digital
currency asking for permission just to
do anything in your life as of course
the richest most powerful people or only
setting policies that are making them
more richer and more powerful than ever
the last few years we have seen the
largest transfer of wealth in I think
recorded human history that is something
worth noting when it comes to robbing
people of any kind of ability not only
to to fight back but to live a life that
that ability has been Stripped Away from
a lot of decent hard-working Americans
that could no longer make ends meet
could no longer act by a society that
that is acting by Fair rules because
it's not everywhere you go there is some
kind of uh nonsense out of some kind of
woke policy there's some kind of bull
crap out there that just robs you of a
good fair and honest living Lucy and I
always make the argument as well because
we're constantly talking against the
world economic Forum George Soros a lot
of these like you'll own nothing in be
happy policies right but we're
essentially already living through that
do we truly own anything if you pay off
your house do you truly own your house
are you still paying property taxes to
the government do you truly have a
constitution do you truly have freedom
of the press and the United States of
America or is Big Tech going to like the
New York Post story with Hunter Biden
kind of censor and suppress what you're
really allowed to say ahead of a uh you
know important election I'm not sure so
you know we have to ask these very
important questions because people are
consistently warning against these
things a warning against this
totalitarian state the authoritarian
government but I for one think that
we're essentially already living through
it and we essentially have this illusion
that we're not but I don't think we're
really free in the United States uh
unfortunately anymore thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time